hi in this video we are going to talk  about what is a LAN LAN is a local area  network so what does it mean imagine you  have your home and you have your own  wireless router you got your desktop  connector your laptop connector and a  printer connected to this router and  your neighbor has a similar setup  he has his home router and desktop is  connected and he's got two laptops and  they are all in their own network so now  what happens is this network which is in  your home is a lamp it is local to your  home and this particular network in your  neighbour's house is a different lamp so  these two are two different local area  networks